and uh particularly this past weekend
i i i heard you saying on the the you
you do you really believe that leg calf
kicks should become
illegal or you just no no i don't know
i was just joking definitely changing
they're so
effective that they're having such a
major impact on nearly every single
fight now
you know so no i was just kind of
kidding because it is now becoming the
ultimate calf kicking championship
if you start dropping those calf kicks
the other guy's [ __ ]
uh so no no i was absolutely kidding i
think it's a tremendous evolution in the
sport and it's a new weapon
that i feel that again as the sport
evolves a little more they're going to
come they're going to find a really good
way of countering them
because a typical leg kick you you block
it you check you lift your leg up
and you kind of block it with the top of
your shin or your knee
and that really hurts the other person
if you're going up against a really good
kicker
if you check that first leg kick
generally they don't throw another one
because you can break their legs right
it really really hurts
with a calf kick you can't really block
it the same way you've just got to not
be there you got to lift it up right you
could have good timing good reflexes but
but yeah no i think they're a fantastic
weapon it was just
just a bit of a joke sure and that's the
thing about it too is that you can
throw the calf kick without really like
putting yourself
in the pocket in any kind of danger you
know like it's just kind of there and
yeah
yeah yeah obviously the legs are longer
than your the arms
you know what i mean so kicks you can
land further away and a calf kick
because it doesn't come up as high
because you always want to look your
opponent in the eye
you know what i'm saying you never look
at where you're going to throw a punch
or a cake because it gives it away
so or you look at the chest you look
there you know sometimes gets a little
weird if you look at them in the eye the
whole time
you know i look at the chest i'm like
okay i'm not going to make out
afterwards buddy
so i look at the chest and and if you're
looking at the chest or the eyes you
don't really see the calf kick because
it's so low
you know what i'm saying so it is hard
to defend for that to defend for that
reason
yeah the ufc has been around for 25
years how how is the calf kick
now becoming popular like a year and a
half ago like how did they not think to
kick that calf
the last 23 years it's a really good
question because it seems so obvious
you know i'm kicking the leg i'm kicking
the thigh i'm kicking the body i'm
kicking the head
uh it just yeah it just never really
caught on i'm sure some people have been
doing it for a long time i'm sure
certain martial arts i've done it for a
long time but it just wasn't popular in
the ufc
and i've i've lived out in thailand you
know for many months and trained out
there extensively and was never
shown a calf kick or anything like that
i'm glad they weren't around when i was
fighting because they look like they
[ __ ] suck
you know what i mean you see the calves
swell up and people
get taken clean off their feet but as i
said he went around in my day and i'm
very grateful
yeah in the last year there's been like
three tkos bites strictly calf kick
wow yeah it's wild it really is it looks
like it hurts like hell because as i say
some people
i forget which one it was saturday night
but dustin jacoby he was the first
fighter of the
uh on the prelims in his last fight he
fought a guy called justin ladet a very
very good boxer
and he just calf kicked him about four
times in a row and that's it he was done
he was on the floor
he managed to get back up but he got up
so so difficultly because of the damage
he just got dropped again when he got
back up but it was all set up from the
calf king so uh
yeah they are they are they're taking
over the sport
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude